so Bloomberg News reporting if you're
looking for Super Bowl tickets but you
don't have the $7,100
cash right now to buy a ticket stub hub
who by the way just sold eBay sold them
for four billion the other day stub up
is partnering with FinTech company a
firm to let customers buy the tickets on
a payment plan starting this week the
us-based customers looking for tickets
from $99 to $17,500 will be able to pay
those off with interest over a period of
up to a year the new partnership between
a firm and eBay marketplace takes effect
this month and covers most sports and
concert tickets payment plans will let
customers buy tickets similar to how
many Americans buy cars homes or large
appliances by taking on debt customers
were looking to buy with a firm's
financing will be asked to provide five
pieces of information and will receive a
credit decision within seconds the two
company said in a statement
approved buyers will be able to select
payment plans that spend 3 6 or 12
months with annual interest rates
ranging from 10% to 30% tickets for the
February 2 game in Miami between the
Kansas City Chiefs and the San Francisco
49ers currently selling on secondary
markets for an average of seven thousand
one hundred dollars each at a twenty
percent rate over six months I'd be an
extra twelve hundred bucks a firm will
pay stub upfront for every transaction
that goes on a payment plan the San
francisco-based FinTech company whose
other partners included did it adidas
Casper Sleep ink and peloton will keep
the interest earned on these purchases
so listen I'm a sports fan and I'll be
watching the Superbowl I watched both
the playoffs my Titans were in the
playoffs i watch all that I've been to
Stanley Cup I'll be going to the Masters
this year I don't mind going to a super
bow you know all of that's fine it's a
luxury well my team your team doesn't
isn't your team you don't own it you
don't play on it you watch it from the
stands and no one knows you're there
it's not your team you are a fan a
spectator you are watching other people
earn a living and that is perfectly fine
to do as long as you have the money to
do it if you are financing your Super
Bowl tickets 30% we might look up stupid
in the dictionary and see your picture
that's absolutely asinine it's
ridiculous it's crazy
you're a fool don't do it don't finance
tickets for anything tickets the sell on
StubHub are 100% entertainment you
cannot buy a ticket to get a kidney
transplant there's nothing on there that
is a necessity it's all a luxury it's
all entertainment and it's all fine to
do if you pay cash and it doesn't affect
your family but by definition if you're
financing a ticket to a game where
someone else is making a living and
you're watching and you're doing that at
30% that puts you in the stupid zone
that's a new seating section right there
in the stadium it's the stupid zone
they're gonna put all the people that
are stupid in one end of the stadium so
we know who you are oh my god this is
unbelievable but it happens all the time
doesn't it it's really not that shocking
we're like oh yeah there's another
stupid thing and and don't you love the
name of the company a firm isn't that
great I'm going to affirm your stupidity
I'm gonna put a 30% tattoo on your
forehead we are going to affirm your
stupidity
I got I got some San Francisco 49er fans
on my team that are wetting their pants
right now I got some Kansas City chief
on my team fans that are wet
pants right now one of my top team
members is a Kansas City guy and he's
going to the Super Bowl but believe me
hey he can afford it and you can be rest
assured the boy did not finance the
tickets otherwise he'd come home to no
job for being that stupid because I try
not to keep people on my payroll that
are that dumb no he'll be the he'll be
enjoying himself and I'm glad he's
getting to go it's a wonderful thing
he's been following the Chiefs for a
long time and it's been 50 years since
they've been there so it's a cool thing
to get to go it's a cool thing but you
know what you watch it on your
television you can get some friends over
you can do a lot of different stuff and
if you can't afford it if your family is
not in control and you don't have an
extra seven thousand dollars plus travel
cost each if you don't have that as
extra money fly it flying around that
means you can't afford it by the way
that means that about almost anything if
you don't have the money to buy it you
can't afford it by definition so this is
just absurd and of course it's a it's
going crazy this idea that StubHub would
use the FinTech company a firm to affirm
your stupidity by loaning you money at
30% or to buy a ticket to anything it's
just it's such crazy stuff that you know
it's going crazy on the internet of
course viral and people keep sending me
this over do you believe this day rim do
you want to do rooms he's gonna say
about that no you didn't you knew what
Dave Ramsey would say about this you're
just trying to stir me up and it worked
[Laughter]
you know it's the same thing though when
you go down by a car and you put on 30%
it's the same thing when you go down by
a couch and you put it on 30% some
people buy stuff and they don't even
look at the paperwork and you imagine
that they only find out later or maybe
never what they paid in fees what they
paid in interest what they really paid
for that couch that was 0% interest
until you didn't pay it off and then
they got you this is the trick people
the most lucrative second
of business in our entire economy are
people that loan you money they're the
most lucrative sector of any part of our
economy the lenders the banks the
lenders the affirms the lenders we can
affirm that borrowing money from a firm
is a bad idea I love it these little
fintechs are so cute yeah and they're
gonna make a billion dollars on it
they're just cute aren't they
people are gonna borrow money to buy
tickets to concerts and sporting events
in the Superbowl on StubHub Wow Wow
I'll be in business forever